alexis basque et français ce pigeon
effectué des livraisons particulières
ont fait partie d'un orchestre
montréalais qui s'appelle l'ensemble
caprice
puis on est ici supporté par la
fondation du grand montréal pour vous
présenter une petite livraison musical
autant de la pandémie
une quarantaine de musiciens feront du
porte-à-porte pour offrir 500 mini
concert ils visiteront cinq
arrondissements montréal pour offrir la
musique en cadeau
[Musique]
honnêtement maintenance et des gants des
masques les instruments j'ai beaucoup de
choses à gérer mais on se dit comme les
gens peuvent plus venir chez nous vers
nous nous avec la musique on va aller
vers les gens et la musique baroque se
prête bien aux concerts extérieurs pour
nous les musiciens baroques
il y a beaucoup de moments dans notre
répertoire où est-ce qu'on devrait jouer
d'or se promener dans les villes il
jouait pour sorte de cérémonie et bien
sûr ça s'était toujours à l'extérieur
cette tournée permet aux musiciens de
revenir à l'essentiel la ferai musique
est là où les gens sont si on peut
rejoindre une personne deux personnes
trois personnes qui sont heureux parce
qu'on fait on peut pas voir plus que ça
une initiative qui réjouit les chanceux
qui ont eu droit ces mini concert
gratuit c'est un bon madame et ça repose
ça fait penser à autre chose parce
qu'autrement on devient trop stressé bah
moi j'aimerais qu'il vienne matin
[Musique]
d'ici mais bien alexandre chartier radio
canada
montréal mais si on portait